rando pays vous propose cette semaine de
continuer la découverte du sud sauvage
avec la traversée du littoral de mare
longue
rendez-vous au baril sur le parking de
la piscine nous y retrouvons thédié
avril
notre accompagnateur du jour
je
commençons cette balade par jeter un
oeil à la piscine d'eau de mer de la
pointe de bétail
très prisé des habitants de saint
philippe elle peut être vidés et fermés
en saison de forte houle
c'est aussi sur ce site qu'on retrouve
le fameux puis des anglais creusé en
1822 dans une coulée son nom ne
viendrait donc pas de l'occupation
anglaise de lille terminé à cette date
en revanche la légende raconte que huit
pièces de monnaies y aurait été
dissimulé lors de sa construction
de retour sur nos pas un petit passage
sur la route permet de retrouver le site
du souffleur d'arbonne et s'appelle
arche naturelle
on bifurque ensuite vers les falaises
sous la forêt de filao les airs de vote
ont récemment été taillé pour signaler
un chemin
puis c'est le passage sous les paccots à
l'emblématique de lac au dessus au
levain quoi c'est d'abord une espèce
très particulière dans sa forme
on voit qu'il a très peu de
ramifications ses ramifications sont
très élancée et au bout de ses
ramifications on va avoir les feuilles
qui sont en fait qui vont pousser en
fait en spirale et qui vont être dans
tes sur les côtés ceva quoi évidemment
dès que l'homme est arrivé à la réunion
tout de suite il a vu un intérêt
l'utilisé d'ailleurs son nom latin ces
bandes anus utilise non utilise parce
que on peut l'utiliser à plusieurs
niveaux alors la première chose
évidemment auquel on pense quand on
parle du bas quoi c'est l'artisanat le
barca est aussi cultivé à saint philippe
donc en fait on va utiliser le chou à
d'autres niveaux on a aussi le fruit
qu'on appelle le pain pas alors le pin
pin évidemment et bien il se consomme
marc il faut savoir le préparer et il ya
très peu de gens qui arrivent à le faire
ambiant différents débats qu avec ces
plantes exotiques qui grimpe sur les
filaos
la deuxième partie de cette traversée du
littoral de mare longue et beaucoup plus
sauvage
on devra allonger les falaises en
faisant attention aux crevasses coincée
entre la mer et la forêt
cette partie du parcours a des airs d'
aventure
dommage que certains ne respectent pas
le site
il est monté à la grande pointe
il faut continuer quelques centaines de
mètres en direction de la mer casse et
c'est ici que l'on retrouve la route qui
matérialise la fin de notre randonnée
ces parcours il est magnifique et
surtout il est très très sauvage et nous
permet de découvrir encore un petit bout
de cette côte du sud sauvage entre le
puits des anglais et la mer casse et
donc on a des des ambiances qui sont
très particulières et parfois assez
insolites comme lorsqu'on traverse la la
forêt de fil à aulaqi est envahi de
philodendron donc c'est des plantes
qu'on rencontre plutôt un appartement en
europe
et puis là qu'ils s'acclimatent très
bien ici dans le sud sauvage
on n'est jamais
très au dessus de la mer en fait les
falaises sont quand même assez bas on
sent bien les embruns c'est une ambiance
du cou qui est assez particulière à
l'endroit sur ce parcours par contre
évidemment il n'y a aucun balisage et
voilà c'est pas c'est pas très indiqué
on va suivre départ un sentier de
pêcheurs et puis en fait très rapidement
on va se retrouver en fait sans sentier
donc on est obligé de longer vraiment là
le bord de la falaise
donc ça passe quand même relativement
bien mais il faut quand même se méfier
il ya des endroits où on est obligé de
passer très près de la falaise
donc c'est ce qui donne aussi son charme
à ce parcours mais il faut être un peu
prudent folk est sûre on franchit aussi
parfois des zones où il ya des failles
quand même assez importante
donc voilà resté un peu un peu vigilants
par rapport à ça